God Saves The King
police had warned demonstrators they
would not tolerate protest if it turned
into disruption and they were backed by
new Wars
by 7 30 they had used them arresting
supporters of the anti-monarchist group
Republic and its leader police said They
seized lock-on devices things that could
be used to lock protesters to railings
according to Republic the devices had an
innocent use I think it's playing out
some of the fears that a lot of
campaigners had about these new acts is
that it gives wide-ranging powers this
this whole notion of being equipped to
lock on right that could be a bike lock
you're carrying to lock your bike up
that could be in this case potentially
like straps that you're using to or like
a padlock that you're using to secure
your van so it's clearly they're
misusing these new powers already and I
think that's pretty concerning the
approved protest site demonstrators were
far outnumbered by Pro royalists it was
mostly good-natured
Police use controversial facial
recognition cameras searching for known
troublemakers
one protester was identified by facial
recognition technology and appear to be
the subject of the new police low
tolerance
[Music]
Patrick salwell was convicted of
throwing eggs
[Music]
[Applause]
oh they were just watching me from their
little Tower over there you know I just
suddenly you know I see all of the
cameras pointing at me all the little
things on a swivel you know and then
they're just like there he is I gave my
little wave and then you know next thing
you know hands behind my back getting
handcuffed snatch Squad moved in and
just um dragged me out basically
near the Mal police arrested supporters
of the just stop oil environment protest
group
I was intending to hold a banner about
the end others were warned about
chanting too loudly why am I being
arrested
Scotland Yard was waiting to release its
arrest figures
Martin brunt Sky News Trafalgar Square